argentina united facing its problems
together that was the message to the
nation given by president alberto
fernandez speaking in the northern
province of turkuman where the
declaration of independence was made 206
years ago
[Applause]
there is no political future if we don't
build on and strengthen every day the
things that unite us
but that is not the message being heard
elsewhere in argentina both left and
right rich and poor marched here in
buenos aires and across the country
separately demanding different things
but both unhappy with the government
what should have been a day of
celebration in argentina has only served
to show the deep divisions in society
here here to my right in front of the
government house is a protest calling
for members of the current government to
be prosecuted for corruption and on my
left on the other side of the police
cordon are those of left-wing groups and
social organizations saying that
argentina should not pay its debt to the
international monetary fund and instead
alleviate poverty
[Music]
these marches are from the shanty towns
and other marginalized communities
low-paid workers calling for the
government to invest in jobs schools and
housing not to pay its crippling debt to
the international monetary fund
they should pay our pensioners for a
youngster's education health care for
our families instead we're paying the
external debt a fraudulent debt
argentina is this year due to pay 19
billion dollars of its debt to the imf
these protesters from more affluent
neighborhoods accuse the government of
mismanagement corruption reserving
special anger for the former president
and current vice president christina
fernandez
we are marching to get rid of this
government you can see how divided
argentinians are christina must go the
president moscow they should all go
analysts predict that inflation this
year will be more than 70
poverty and unemployment are rising the
economy minister resigned last week and
confidence in a divided government is
waning
all this makes argentina vulnerable to
the rising fuel and food prices hitting
much of the rest of the world as those
prices continue to rise the divisions
are only likely to deepen
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires